want to know how to hide a billion euros
while the Panama papers a biggest data
leak in history laid bare the
exploitation of secretive tax regimes by
the world's most powerful two thousand
six hundred gigabytes of data uncovered
11.5 million secret files showing her
former and sitting politicians officials
and beloved celebrities had funneled
fund through a law firm in Panama to
offshore accounts in tax havens such as
the British Virgin Islands the Bahamas
to seychelles by passing tax authorities
so if you're wondering if this story
seems familiar well we've been here
before so to speak in 2014 there was a
luxe leaks multinational team this
occasion where the tax evaders the
european parliament set up a special
committee on tax returns to look into it
but it had limited powers this time
around they will have inquiry committee
the factor being an inquiry committee
immediately allows the Parliament
greater legal tools at their disposal to
get to the bottom of tax evasion
practices particular to look closely at
tax havens and tax loopholes they will
also have better access to people and
confidential documents the committee
will consist of 65 ups and we'll have
the twelfth month mandate the task ahead
of them is a difficult one banking
offshore isn't illegal but not declaring
it to relevant tax authorities is the
hope is that these recommendations can
influence better tax practices
throughout you
I